they are touted by the US government as
a bigger threat than Isis that's
plotting to attack the United States the
horizon-- group is being targeted by US
airstrikes in Syria never heard of them
well that's because they might not exist
the US government says they are seasoned
al Qaeda members from Afghanistan
Pakistan and Yemen their name comes from
the historical region of horison but
some experts say there's nothing to
suggest that the horizon-- group is
distinct from Al Qaeda's Syria branch
jabhat Al nusra so why is the u.s.
saying it's targeting a group that may
not exist
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now